let's go to this week's mailbag always
glad to get emails and messages from
people mostly glad anyway not i guess i
can't say always but generally speaking
you can email info davidpakman.com if
you have something to say keep it polite
keep it quick keep it substantive and
many things this week meeting those uh
requirements not all let's start with a
couple of wackier message no bs wrote in
and said without any evidence i should
add you were paid by the demo rats to
spread disinformation and lies with no
shame no wonder you come from one of the
most corrupt countries in the world
that's a reference to argentina
argentina is very corrupt that's true
you lied and lied since 2016 it started
with trump russia when it was proven
recently it was all a hoax that's not
true you didn't even admit it satan is
all over you but judgment day will come
i don't care about your religious
nonsense
but
prove i'm paid by the democrats that's
most of this is not the most of these
are not even empirical statements we
can't even i mean you know
satan will one day unleash uh judgment
day upon me neither one of us will ever
know that
um but
there's a specific claim that i'm paid
by the demo rats let's assume they mean
the democrats
prove it
prove it i would encoura you know every
day david you're paid by the democrats
david you're paid by george soros
shoros you guys know about that right um
prove it is my request to you thank you
very much jason wrote in and said your
show sucks ass
the little remarks you make during a
trump rally are idiotic you chime in on
the tiniest things trump says but the
big facts you completely ignore
shut up and listen and don't interrupt
perhaps you just shouldn't cover his
rallies
you're a tiny little man that hides
behind a microphone you should try maybe
play-by-play
for the nhl maybe oh i would love to do
that thank you now that it's a
completely unhinged message at first i
don't know if you're making fun of
me for a stutter i don't have or i know
lots of people on the right have been
making fun of joe biden for having a
stutter i don't know anything about the
stutter part
but
i would be totally up for doing some
sports play-by-play i think it would be
an incredible
uh thing to learn and jason listen if
you can help get me in
i would love to do that on the weekends
brett wrote in about tulsi gabbard and
says tulsi maintains that the leaker was
trying to interfere with the normal
supreme court process isn't that the
same as what the peaceful protesters
were trying to do on january 6 right
well no because they you have to
remember brett
the january six protesters just wanted
to
make sure there was no fraud
um
and okay they wanted to prevent the
election from being certified but that
would have been wrong then or something
and then the supreme court leaker
was doing something wrong even though no
crime was committed there
but 700 people have been accused of
crimes related to the trump rights don't
worry about any of that brett just
listen to tulsi she'll always tell you
the truth i'm sure
i got a message about my interest rate
segment
which said pete wrote in and said you
said to let you know if the interest
rate hike segment was useful
and i just wanted to say it was very
useful cnn and msnbc haven't explained
it that straightforward please keep
educating us you're good at explaining
things thank you pete well i really
appreciate that and like i said
those segments
almost no one watches them
but i enjoy doing them and the people
that do watch them
seem to get a lot out of them so we'll
we'll keep doing it i have no problem
with that whatsoever
let's go to our next email this one is
from john about strengthening the dollar
john says david sir i had a quick
question about strengthen the dollar i'm
a union member and recently had a
conversation with an older woman that's
also a union member and she mentioned
the phrase strengthen the dollar which i
honestly am not 100 sure what that means
but i told her so if you work the next
six months straight with our wages how
does that affect you personally and she
had that deer in the headlights look on
her face literally her eyebrows went up
quite funny because she looked so
shocked then didn't have an answer
literally said she didn't know funny
thing is i don't really know the
significance of that either i've just
learned to ask why
i also have a friend in his mid-40s
during a conversation he said something
about biden weakening the dollar
now this friend is on disability and
doesn't work so i asked him why does
that matter to you
no offense but you're on disability and
i'm pretty sure you'll be fine
yes uh that that is generally true
um and i don't honestly know about that
either but i also don't think it would
but he said the same thing a pause
and then i don't know
um
so okay here's the deal with the
strength of the dollar stuff
as a general principle
when people say a stronger dollar they
mean the dollar is worth more relative
to other currencies so there's a crazy
situation right now where the dollar
nominally is now worth more
uh or right it's almost equivalent
to the euro the value of the dollar has
increased significantly over the last
year and a half relative to the euro so
number one is a lot of people who talk
about strengthening the dollar don't
even really know how it would help them
the way it would help is it would make
imports relatively less expensive all
else being equal
okay
the funniest part is a lot of the people
saying strength in the dollar don't know
that the dollar is much stronger now
than it has been in a while and i'm not
even saying biden gets the credit for
that i'm just saying it is and many
people
extraordinarily confused so john you did
a great thing which is you asked
specific questions how would that affect
you and they don't know
that doesn't mean it wouldn't affect
them they just have no idea why which is
basically just as funny
douglas wrote in about refuting election
conspiracy theorists and said many
republican candidates you interview
assert that the election was stolen none
are ever specific on how such a
conspiracy could have been carried out
in multiple states
one who directed the conspiracy
two how many people were involved and at
what levels
three why have there been no
whistleblowers well they would say that
there have been they would say the
affidavits are whistleblowers instead
they gish gallop and regurgitate mike
pillow's talking points about how many
votes were stolen in what states
can you please hold their feet to the
fire about the specifics of the
conspiracy itself i'm going to try to do
a better job on that these are all good
questions
they will what you have to remember is
it's really common to come across
something like this and think this is
bulletproof when they start spouting you
just say who directed it
how many people were involved
and why have there been no
whistleblowers and they will tell you
with a straight face
we don't even know the full scope of who
directed it but it was democrats as well
as antifa you know whatever they'll have
an answer
and when you say how many people were
involved they'll say
it could be thousands of people and then
you'll say well why have there been no
whistleblowers and they'll say there
have been look at all of the affidavits
that were brought forward and then you
have to say well but affidavits aren't
evidence in a strict sense and that
you're in the weeds so
never underestimate their ability to put
you in the weeds no matter what sort of
refutation you offer
coop wrote in
and said hey david sorry buddy
but the facial hair isn't a good look
for you my opinion only so take it for
what it's worth i will coop thank you
i'm gonna take it for nothing
that's how much it's worth to me
uh
i i just this is not a big deal guys
climate change invasion of ukraine
roe v wade overturned
weaponized trumpism my facial hair is
very very low
on the list of priorities but coop does
say keep up the good work
which i appreciate
i appreciate that thank you
dan wrote in and said
cultural marxists i i love this with the
question mark it's great david greatly
appreciate your work and was wondering
if i could get your thoughts on the
cultural marxists phrase that gets
thrown around by the right even a
british conservative politician used it
recently it seems interchangeable with
post-modernism woke mob political
correctness critical race theory and is
it possibly means little but it's just a
scary term the right uses to reference
something bad i'd be interested in your
help many thanks dan yes so cultural
marxism is another
right-wing conspiracy theory it has a
bit of an anti-semitic twist
the idea is that cultural marxism is a
philosophy or world view
that will wreck and destroy american
culture and american morality as
right-wingers see it
cultural marxism can be thought of as a
sort of political correctness on
steroids it's an assault on the american
way of life now
in its original form the idea here is
that there's a group of jewish
philosophers who fled germany in the
1930s
went to teach at columbia university and
came up with this form of marxism that
is focused on american culture it's you
might think well marxism is an economic
philosophy or a political philosophy no
the idea is these jewish individuals who
fled germany in the world war ii era
came to the us and said we are going to
use marxism on
american culture
and um
that's the kind of
anti-semitic element which oftentimes
the people talking about cultural
marxism are also very suspicious and
concerned about the role of jews in
american culture
and um
it's
what what it means today to people who
even know what they mean by it and some
of them don't
they mean that
jewish marxists or left-wing marxists
are going to invade american culture
by taking over
media systems
education
schools universities etc
and um
do bad things and it's all gonna be
terrible it's more or less the uh the
gist of it so that's cultural marxism
you can essentially i mean listen
i'm not saying ignore everything anyone
says when they use the phrase cultural
marxism but when someone says cultural
marxism unironically it should
definitely be a red flag for you that
you should really carefully scrutinize
everything that this person is saying
send in your emails if you'd like to be
featured next week info
davidpakman.com
monday may 30th we'll be doing a one day
membership special to commemorate
memorial day you can get on our
newsletter at davidpakman.com
and then monday memorial day you'll get
an email telling you how to take
advantage of this great membership
special we will see you on the bonus
show today